[Music]
time now for morning rounds with CBS
News medical contributors dr. Tara
narula and dr. David agus first up
something that affects millions of
Americans dementia there was encouraging
news this week from the American Medical
Association's internal medicine journal
which reported a nationwide decline in
the prevalence of dementia the study
compared statistics from 2002-2012 and
found the prevalence rate of dementia
among American 65 and older fell from
nearly twelve percent to just under nine
percent David what is to credit for the
decline it's very positive obviously and
you know it's it's big data so we're not
quite sure their reasons but what we
think is is that dementia goes with
education the more educated you are the
less dementia happens over time and the
population is getting more educated you
know there's wild data from Europe that
every year you delay retirement you
reduce the incidence of Alzheimer's or
dementia by 3% well so retiring 85 now
working from Attica less than 65 but you
know people who are more educated they
take their medicines more they have
better health care and they use their
brains more and so the hope is is that
we can learn from this and actually push
more people into that track what tire
does this mean that the overall number
of people with dementia is now expected
to decline because we've predicted
they're going to increase substantially
right so these types of diseases are so
frightening and devastating because they
strip you of who you are and what David
said that this gives us hope that we can
find ways to reduce this risk but the
issue is that while the prevalence rate
is going down the overall prevalence are
a number of disease cases is expected to
rise as we see aging of the population
so right now we have about five million
Americans over 65 with alzheimer's and
dementia by 2050 that number is expected
to triple to about 13.8 million so again
still this pressing need for aggressive
research into these diseases David to
dig into the education piece a little
bit more so is that does that exist
across other diseases as well well
certainly you know people higher
socioeconomic status use more healthcare
and so there better prevention they're
better at you knowing what to do and
hopefully taking the medicines and what
it learned for all of us in medicine is
we got
j/k better we got to push people you
don't use it you lose it especially with
the brain so figure out ways to be
uncomfortable to make your brain learn
you know drive a different way to work
every day take your watch from your left
hand put it on your right hand we
arrange your furniture your bedroom they
matter it's building new neural pathways
exactly let your brain learn a language
fascinating our next topic strokes while
the overall rate of strokes has been
declining for decades the risk levels
are rising for a certain age group and
it's not the elderly a study published
in the Journal of the American Heart
Association found that over two time
periods one from nineteen ninety five to
nineteen ninety nine in the second from
2010 to 2014 ischemic strokes which are
the most common type more than doubled
in patients ages 35 to 39 stroke rates
were also up among those ages 40 to 50
for but there was a decline in patients
older than 55 David what are some of the
possible reasons for these increases you
know the generation before actually had
the lowest stroke rate we've ever seen
so all of a sudden we're seeing stroke
goes up at the same time we're seeing
weight go up we're seeing diabetes go up
and what we know is that stroke
associates with those two disorders and
so we have pay attention again this is a
big data we don't exactly know the cause
but these associations are real Terra
the study also looked at heart attack
rates what did we find so while the
rates of stroke went up for these
younger populations interestingly the
rates of what we call st elevation heart
attacks the type of heart attack where
blood flows completely occluded in one
of the arteries to the heart muscle
those rates went down across all great
age groups in particular in the young
the rates kind of petered out or stayed
steady in the last five years of the
study but what this says is that you
know maybe we are doing a better job
with our preventive efforts with aspirin
with statins with decreased smoking
rates why there's this difference
between stroke and heart attack a little
bit unclear it may be that some of the
risk factors like high blood pressure
for instance may be more relevant for
stroke at younger ages than maybe offend
heart attack which may have more to do
with abnormal cholesterol levels in
addition there's other risk factors for
stroke like atrial fibrillation or
abnormal heart rhythms that again may be
more important in terms of stroke risk
in the younger population we're seeing
increasing prevalence of
some of those arrhythmias if these
trends continue among younger age groups
terrible i mean what's the potential
impact here you know as a cardiologist
it's just it's so devastating when you
see young people in the prime of their
life 30s and 40s with families working
suddenly becoming disabled and that's
the problem with a lot of these diseases
it's not just that it can kill you is
that it can leave you crippled mentally
and physically you can't walk c function
and this is for the next 30 or 40 years
a lot of young people think that you
know if I feel well I'm fine but these
disease processes are silent and as
David mentioned so important to take
control x doing preventive measures
controlling blood pressure not smoking
exercising controlling weight we can
really reverse this trend David how do
you convince young people they're not
invincible that's a million-dollar
question right some 120 to do something
helping with you in there six exactly
uranium it's difficult we don't have a
metric we don't have a number for health
on our watch to tell us what's going on
so that's one of the million-dollar
questions in how that we got to figure
out better to me it's education right
you explained somebody why you don't
tell them what to do you explain to them
why and the behavior starts to change
yeah but I don't I mean I've got a 16
year old it and a 20 year old ain't
thinking of six-year-olds you don't want
to do it otherwise it just even the best
education it's like they don't see past
you know next year it's you know I mean
it's certainly a major issue and so
there's no other way around it is the
only way is that if we start to get
healthier and prevent disease I mean
it's one of critical problems in our
country right is that many of these
diseases are delay alors preventable
we're not doing it yeah all right
finally for years we've seen the ads
asking got milk well the question might
have might should be got the right milk
parents might assume that lower fat milk
is healthier but that might not be the
case a new study published by the
American Journal of Clinical Nutrition
looked at more than 2,000 kids aged 6
and younger it found that those who
drink whole milk compared to one percent
milk had higher amounts of vitamin D and
a lower body mass index I am surprised
David what the what well I mean there
are a lot of ways to look at it again
it's not a randomized study so maybe as
kids got you know more
fatter the parents in listen I'm going
to switch them from whole milk talofa
milk and that's why there's association
but the other is is that when you drink
whole milk you know you're filled yeah
and so you may not have the Twinkies or
the other junk foods and that maybe we
have to learn from these associations
but it clearly doesn't necessarily show
causality I'm a two percent guy Roger
heavy green all right doctors David agus
and Tara narula thank you both very much